hey you guys flickers of fear time my
movie review series and we're continuing
on with
giallo july now of course she knew that
i wasn't going to be able to get through
this entire month without talking about
one of the directors uh if not the
director that's most associated with the
jello genre and that would be daario
argento now i've actually covered a lot
of dario's kind of better known movies i
guess like deep red and tenebrae and
suspiria obviously inferno so i decided
to go with one of his giallo movies that
is probably not that much seen or not uh
as remembered as well as some of his uh
other stuff and so i'm going to be
talking today about the 1971 film
the cata 9 tales
now i had actually seen this who
probably like 20 years ago or something
like that and didn't really remember
that much about it so i had really been
wanting to revisit it
you know to kind of see i don't know
just see like how the land lays or
anything like that now
this movie is only dario argento's
second movie
and
you can still like to an extent you can
still tell it's a dario argento movie
like like i said if you're familiar with
his later stuff like you can see like
some of the hallmarks
of his later work but i will say that
this movie is actually
considering what his later stuff is like
was actually like pretty restrained it's
a pretty standard murder mystery um you
know and it has like some kind of weird
touches to it but
not as bizarre like operatic as like
some of his uh other stuff now daario
has admitted uh on multiple occasions
this is actually his least favorite film
of all the films he made he's made now
he said this many years ago i'm not sure
if that still applies nowadays because
um you know if you follow his work at
all uh i i'm gonna kind of say like
since the 1990s
um his work has been a little hit or
miss like to put it kindly i think like
the last movie of his that i really
liked was
stendall syndrome and that was 1996 and
there were some in there that i didn't
see so the screenplay of cat and
ninetales uh was actually written mostly
by dario argento in collaboration with
uh dardano sachetti who actually worked
primarily later on with uh lamberto bava
and also with lucio folchi he actually
wrote uh one of my favorite folgi films
which is the psychic and there was also
some i believe uncredited work in there
by uh brian edgar wallace who is the son
of the very very famous english crime
writer edgar wallace who a lot of yellow
movies like were based on his stuff um
but yeah so brian edgar wallace is a
crime writer in his own right and he
like helped come up with this story as
well but like when the production
started there was a lot of dispute over
the writing
because daario insisted that he be given
soul screen writing credit
because the bulk of the production was
based around i guess like the first 40
pages of the script because i think like
he wrote half and like dardano society
wrote half so daria wrote like the first
half that's what the production was so
he's like well i should get the only
screenwriting credit and dardano would
only get like the story credit which you
know is you don't get as much money for
that um so there was kind of like a big
rift they had like a big pretty big like
public feud about it at the time and i'm
actually not sure if or when this was
ever mended i will go on to say that
like society later on
like in the 1980s he worked on uh demons
and demons too which were produced by
dario argento so i don't know if they
had any uh collaboration or if they you
know were talking to each other at that
point maybe they did bear at the hat
bury the hatchet at some point i'm not
entirely sure so the cat of nine tails
it's kind of considered the second or
the middle film i guess in argento's
actually unconnected animal trilogy they
call it that uh the first of which which
is his first movie was the bird with the
crystal plumage from 1970 and then the
third was also coming out in 1871 and
that was called four flies on gray
velvet now the cat and ninetales despite
its title does not feature uh an actual
cat sadly because that would have that
would that would have really like added
something to it there's not an actual
cat in it and there's not even like a
cat and nine tails like a whip you know
what i mean there's not one of those uh
either for that matter uh the phrase
actually refers and this is a little bit
i don't know i feel like it was just
kind of like convoluted it's just kind
of like squeezed in there but it
actually refers to like the nine leads
or the investigative threads that the
amateur detectives in the movie are
pursuing so it's almost kind of like
like one of them makes a comment it's
like oh nine leads it's like a cat with
nine tails or something like that which
like i said doesn't make a lot of sense
but whatever but that's like what the
name of the movie means they very
specifically say it so the plot of this
movie
revolves around a blind man named franco
arno i think is his last name now he's
played by carl mauldin
there's actually like a lot of well not
a lot but there's like a couple of
american actors in here it's you know
like a lot of glo movies they kind of
have like a international cast and then
they just dub it all into one language
this is actually not dubbed into english
this is actually dubbed into italian at
least the version that i watched so it's
very very funny to see like carl maldon
and like other american actors that you
know are american actors and like seeing
them dubbed into italian i don't know i
thought it was amusing anyway carl
mauldin plays this blind guy
named franco now he's walking down the
street one evening with his little niece
laurie
like he's her guardian i guess because
like her parents died or whatever now he
has super sensitive hearing like you
know like a lot of blind people do
and he picks up what sounds like this
court like
shady sounding conversation having
something to do with blackmail and it's
like this guy he's in a in a car or
something like that and he's talking and
he asks like the little girl hey like
why don't you check out that dude or
like what kind of car it is or blah blah
blah because he thinks that like
something shifty is going on now the
following day he actually finds out that
the building that he was walking past
when he heard this particular
conversation
has been broken into
now they don't think that anything was
stolen at least at first um and but one
guard was i can't remember if he was
actually like hurt or killed but like
the guard at the front gate like
somebody you know knocked him
unconscious or killed him or something
so but yeah they're like yeah so there's
a break in but we don't think anything
is missing like it looked like nobody
took anything now this building actually
turns out to be the headquarters of a
genetic research facility that's called
the tertsy institut turtsie institute
and one doctor who works there his name
is dr calabresi
he kind of like on the down low
he tells his fiance bianca oh there
actually was something taken from here
last night and i know exactly what it is
and i know exactly who took it
see that's what you don't like say [ __ ]
like that out loud because
uh not too long after that calabrese is
going to the train station to meet the
person who took the whatever it was like
presumably he's going to blackmail him
like hey i know what you did um i know
what you took
so he goes to meet this guy and then
somehow
accidentally ends up falling in front of
the train and getting squished
now again like the cops just think oh
you know he tripped and fell in front of
the train too bad so sad uh so they are
not treating it as a homicide now at
this point uh you have a journalist by
the name of carlo jordani and he's
played by another american actor james
franciscus
so he gets involved at this point
and franco the blind guy uh he actually
believes that calabrese was murdered
because he thinks that there was some
kind of connection between the
conversation that he overheard the
break-in and this guy dying like the
very next day so he's like yeah there's
got to be something going on there so
franco contacts the journalists jordana
giordani
with his like suspicions
now what ended up happening was that it
so happened that when calabrese fell in
front of the train there was a
photographer there and he got a picture
of the guy like one of course they like
put it in the paper like this guy going
oh [ __ ] like right in front of the trade
it's like it was pretty hilarious i mean
it's not wouldn't be hilarious if you
actually saw that or like if it actually
happened to you obviously but in the
movie it was like kind of funny so he
got a picture of it
but franco is actually convinced that
the published photo that they put in the
newspaper he's like i'm curious to know
was that photo cropped
so
him and uh jordani they go to the
photographer and the photographer was
like yeah we did crop it like to fit it
into the space or whatever and he's like
can we look at the actual negative go
look at the actual negative and see what
you can see so he goes in there and sees
the actual photo that he took that
wasn't cropped and looks at it like
under the the little loop thing or
whatever and he sees there's like a
blurry like hand someone is obviously
like pushing the guy like in front of
the train so he's like holy [ __ ] the guy
was murdered seconds after that no i'm
talking about maybe maybe a minute after
that the photographer
is also killed he's actually strangled
or like garrotted or whatever uh in his
dark room
and the original negative as long
as well as the photos that he had
printed from the negative are stolen
so obviously you know somebody the
killer doesn't want anybody to know what
the [ __ ] going on
so from this point forward uh jordani
and franco are on the case they kind of
like team up and they're gonna like work
together see what happened was franco
he was blinded in an accident at some
point in the past they don't really get
too much into that but he says before
that he was also a journalist like a
reporter um now he just he makes
crossroad puzzles or something like that
but he said he really really is into
puzzles and so he's very excited about
getting to the bottom of the mystery and
everything like that
so
the duo
discover that the turtle institute
one of their big projects that they've
been working on
has to do with xyy syndrome
which is an actual thing
but in the 1970s
there was a theory going around which
has since been discredited
that people that were born with this
particular
condition like xy chromosomes um were
supposedly like genetically predisposed
to criminal behavior there was like some
kind of thing that went around it's like
oh we tested like all of these prisoners
and like all of them had that or
something like that like i said that
that's been discredited that's actually
not the case it is a chromosomal like
aberration but it doesn't like have a
huge like some people don't even know
that they have it like it doesn't really
have any huge like they said sometimes
the people have it they're a little bit
taller or they have they tend to have
like more learning difficulties or
something like that but nothing like
criminal behavior anything like it's
very very low key
but in the 1970s they did believe that
so that's kind of like what
uh what the plot of this movie sort of
like hinges around is this particular uh
chromosomal uh abnormality so as i
mentioned the cat and ninetails the cat
with nine tails um that refers to like
the leads that they're following like i
said this sounded like when they laid it
out i was just kind of like okay that
didn't really sound like it made any
sense but okay
so the nine leads are actually like the
five remaining doctors at the institute
because like one of them got squished by
a train obviously but the other five so
those are like suspects there's two more
suspects the guy who got squashed by the
train like his fiancee bianca because he
told her you know i know who stole the
[ __ ] so maybe she told the killer you
know so that's a lead and then uh the
guy that owns the institute tertsy he
has a daughter
named anna
who
it's kind of like turns out to be like a
big plot point or like a red herring or
something like that that she's his
daughter but she's like his adopted
daughter and also maybe he kind of has
like a thing for her it's like it's a
little weird there's like all kind of
like crazy like weird [ __ ] it's not
crazy it's just like there's just like
weird [ __ ] going on here and then i
think the other leads are considered to
be like the photographs
and the break-in and then there's like
this note
that bianca supposedly had like in her
locket or something like that so
basically franco and jordani they start
investigating each lead kind of one by
one
but every single time they go downwards
like it either ends up within like a
dead end or an actual like dead person
um you know as as
various like ones of their suspects like
start turning up dead as well
and they also have their lives
threatened on several occasions uh you
know one of them
i can't remember like what the killer
tried to do to the blind guy because
they just i don't think they show it
they just kind of like he just says over
the phone but james franciscus um you
know jordani he gets almost gets like
poisoned by like somebody comes in and
like injects poison into
these milk thing like milk bags that he
has and he's gonna drink the milk
because that's all
he has in the apartment and like anna
comes over and they're like having like
a romantic evening he's like want some
milk that's all i got i'm like ooh you
smooth talker but yeah um but they don't
but yeah it has poison in it so they do
kind of have that so yeah you got poison
milk you got like a really actually
probably my favorite sequence in it
where
they have to like go to
the cemetery at night and they're like
creeping around in this vault because
they're looking for this locket um you
know that supposedly has this note in it
so that's like really cool like them
creeping through the cemetery one of the
doctors at the institute this is it's
1971 y'all they think that he's a
suspect
pretty much
only because as far as i am aware only
because
he's gay and he hangs out like at this
like a gay bar called like i think it's
called saint peter's or something like
that so it's like just the fact that he
does that they're like oh sketchy so
like they have to like look into that so
i thought that was like okay like i said
1971. so there's that yeah like i said
there's a whole thing with turtzie and
his daughter but she's not really his
genetic daughter or like his biological
daughter so maybe he has like he's in
love with her it's like i don't know
it's super weird um
and anna start a fling they have a thing
going on uh there's a really weird scene
with like this really hostile
barber
that's like given like you know doing
the thing the shaven uh james franciscus
with the straight razor and it's like
being real [ __ ] they think a barber
did this like is the murderer and he's
like i'll show them it's just like it
was really funny and that guy like never
shows up again so i just thought that
was kind of funny and then there's also
this other
that's what i'm saying about like this
being a pretty standard like murder
mystery but there's all these like just
weird little details in there so you can
kind of tell it's like dario or gento
there's also this character in there
what's he called i think he's called
gigi the loser he gets kind of like
pressed into service because i guess
he's like a criminal but he's like a
safe cracker like he can open safes and
stuff but when he's introduced he's not
only in it for like a minute or
something but when he's introduced it's
in this bar
and he's having like a swearing contest
like with this old guy and people are
like taking bets
on who can come up with the most
i guess like the the most insults would
like for the other person without like
repeating anything like you have to just
keep coming up with them and stuff i'm
just kind of like was that a thing in
italy all right that's that sounds fun
but yeah so there's that just like like
i said just random kind of like details
um so yeah so there's like a lot of
strange little touches like that as sort
of the mystery becomes you know it
starts to get resolved it gets unraveled
or whatever but you know as i mentioned
this is pretty subdued uh you know
especially if you've seen some of our
argento's like leader stuff you know the
cinematography is pretty unobtrusive
pretty workmanlike um there are a couple
cool shots in there but it's not like
you know like i said it's not like
operatic or lurid or anything like later
like his later stuff
and another thing too is that the a lot
of people get killed but the kills
aren't really all that gruesome like
mostly like i said people are just like
strangled or garrotted or they're just
kind of like killed off screen
it's really not all that violent now the
guy getting hit by the train is pretty
good like because there's like a very
funny like close-up of like his the
train like hitting his the side of his
face and like blood coming out and then
like his body's like
like underneath the trade and there's
also like a really good scene with like
a guy falling down an elevator shaft and
like his hands like on the ropes going
like
like that that's like i like that a lot
but other than that it's like pretty
like it's pretty subdued like as far as
like the kills and stuff go there's no
you know oh we're gonna stab somebody's
like opal like beating heart that's like
just like open in their chest or
something like that it's not like real
splashy like that so the mystery like
kind of at the heart of the movie is
properly convoluted there's a lot of red
herrings and stuff just like most giallo
movies
but i have to say that this one i think
like the resolution of the mystery like
fell
a little flat for me and what i mean by
that is that i kind of found it
difficult to believe that the killer
would go to all the trouble he went to
for what seemed like kind of a petty or
like not really like a pretty trivial
reason you know what i mean it really
didn't seem like
i don't know it didn't seem important
enough to like kill a whole bunch of
people over is what i'm saying but i
will say like on the plus side i really
did like you know carl maldon and james
franciscus like teaming up like the you
know detective team or whatever i
thought they were really good together
it's kind of like hard to
because because they're dubbed into
italian which like i said was kind of
amusing so you don't really get their
natural voices and stuff but i mean just
their body language and stuff they
seemed like they seemed like a good team
you know what i mean i liked the the
pairing of them together and you know
and the little girl like coming along
you know uh carl baldwin's like niece
lori like her being along too and her
getting in danger like later on so that
was good as well because she was like
really cute so i mean the plot is a
little bit slow-moving and i don't think
it hangs together quite as well as some
of argento's later films like i said
some of it seems a little
forced or kind of like all over the
place but one another thing that i did
like was there's this kind of
i guess like repeated
sort of like thematic resonance having
to do with nature versus nurture that's
kind of like seems like the organizing
you know theme of the whole thing with
it and it kind of like reflects in a lot
of people's
uh relationships and a lot of the
scenarios that happen throughout the
movie so i kind of feel like that's like
i said like an organizational kind of
motif so i don't know i feel like this
is kind of one of argento's probably
lesser discussed works you don't really
even people when they talk about argento
don't really talk about it all that much
um and i can probably see why it's a
good movie but it's not
you know like iconic it doesn't stand
out like some of his other ones do but
if you're a fan it's still absolutely
worth watching i mean if you like giallo
movies this is actually like a really
really good one i mean i've seen way
worse than the worst ones than this for
sure um this one actually does make
sense and it does have like you know
resolution of the mystery and it's not
you know it's not real
visually appealing but it's still like a
good character study and it's the
mystery is kind of interesting
i will say though that
i actually like his first movie the bird
with the crystal plumage better than
this one and i think contemporary
audiences were kind of like in agreement
on that one because i feel like bird
with a crystal plumage came out in 1970
and it was like a really big hit i mean
that was his first movie and then he
made this one and everyone's like
you know what i mean like that one's
that one's okay but it wasn't as good as
the first one and i don't think it's as
good as the first one but it's still
like absolutely worth watching it does
have a lot to recommend it i'm but i'm
only going to suggest if you've already
seen like all his other like big like
iconic movies um and you want to just
kind of like delve deeper into his
filmography or something like that like
especially it's interesting to see some
of his early works you know what i mean
because he's
he just got so well known for doing
stuff in like the late 70s like with
suspiria and tenebrae and well tenta
bray was 80s but you know in deep red
and stuff but this is like a few years
before that so it was just kind of like
interesting to see him when he was still
like in his in his baby director phase
so yeah this is actually um i think
was it arrow or i can't remember who it
was it might have been arrow and they
just put out a really really nice like
limited edition
uh blu-ray of this it's got like posters
and all kind of like uh extra [ __ ] on it
um which actually looks really really
good i mean they always do like a really
good job if it's arrow i'm pretty sure
it is but it's if you want to watch it
for free it's on 2b and i think it's on
several other streaming services as well
uh for free i think it might be on roku
and stuff like that too so check it out
um or if you've seen it let me know what
you think about it in the comments and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear continuing on with giallo july so
hopefully you'll tune in for the next
one and that'll do it for this time
around bye